The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SPEAKER 1: Welcome to
this Vensim tutorial.
As a group of students engaged
in the system dynamics seminar
at MIT Sloan, we
will present how
to estimate model parameters
and the confidence interval
in a dynamic model using Maximum
Likelihood Estimation, MLE,
Likelihood Ratio, LR method.
First, the basics of MLE
are described, as well as
the advantages and
underlying assumptions.
Next, the different methods
available for finding
confidence intervals of
the estimated parameters
are discussed.
Then, a step-by-step guide
to a parameter estimation
using MLE-- an assessment
of the uncertainty
around parameter estimates using
Univariant Likelihood Ratio
Method in Vensim-- is provided.
This video is presented to you
by William, George, Sergey,
and Jim under the guidance of
Professor Hazhir Rahmandad.
The literature, Struben,
Sterman, and Keith,
highlight that estimating model
parameters and the uncertainty
of these parameters are central
to good dynamic modeling
practice.
Models must be grounded
in data if modelers
are to provide reliable
advice to policymakers.
Ideally, one should
estimate model parameters
using data that are independent
of the model behavior.
Often, however, such
direct estimation
from independent
data is not possible.
In practice, modelers
must frequently
estimate at least
some model parameters
using historical data itself,
finding the set of parameters
that minimize the difference
between the historical and
simulated time series.
Only then can estimations
of model parameters
and uncertainties
of these estimations
serve to test model
hypotheses and quantify
important uncertainties, which
are crucial for decision-making
based on modeling outcome.
Therefore, when modeling
a system in Vensim,
if the purpose of this model
involves numerical testing
or projection, robust
statistical parameter
estimation is necessary.
Confidence intervals also
serve as an important tool
for decision-making based
on modeling outcomes.
Various approaches are
available to estimate parameters
in confidence intervals in
dynamic model, including,
for estimation, the
generalized methods of moments
in maximum likelihood, and
for confidence intervals,
likelihood-based methods
and bootstrapping.
Maximum Likelihood Estimation
is becoming increasingly
important for
nonlinear models when
estimating nonlinear
parameters that
consist of non-normal,
autocorrelated errors,
and heteroscedasticity.
It is simpler to understand
the construct, yet
at the same time,
requires relatively little
computational power.
MLE is best suitable for
using historical data
to generate parameter
estimation and confidence
intervals as long as
errors of estimation
are independent and
identically distributed.
When using MLE in
complex systems
where these assumptions
are violated,
and/or the analytical
likelihood function
might be difficult
to find, one should
use more advanced methods.
This tutorial will not
address these cases.
As the demonstration will
show, the average laptop
in use in 2014 is capable
of running the analysis
in a few minutes or less.
This tutorial is based on the
following four references--
"Bootstrapping for confidence
interval estimation
and hypothesis testing for
parameters of system dynamics
models" by Dogan, "A behavioral
approach to feedback loop
dominance analysis" by
Ford, "Modeling Managerial
Behavior," also known as
"The Beer Game" by Sterman,
and a soon-to-be published text
by Struben, Sterman, and Keith,
"Parameter and Confidence
Interval Estimation in Dynamic
Models-- Maximum Likelihood
and Bootstrapping Methods."
More background and explanation
on the theory of MLE
can be found in these works.
This tutorial will focus on the
application of MLE in Vensim.
The literature, Struben,
Sterman, and Keith,
stresses that
modelers must not only
estimate parameter values,
but also the uncertainty
in the estimates so they
and others can determine
how much confidence to
place in the estimates
and select appropriate ranges
for sensitivity analysis
in order to assess the
robustness of the conclusions.
Estimating confidence
intervals can
be thought of as
finding the shape
of the inverted bowl, Figure 2.
If for a given data set,
the likelihood function
for a set of parameters
falls off very steeply
for even small departures
from the best estimate,
then one can have confidence
that the true parameters
are close to the
estimated value.
As always, assuming the
model is correctly specified,
another maintained
hypothesis are satisfied.
If the likelihood
falls off only slowly,
other values of the parameters
are nearly as likely
as the best estimates and one
cannot have much confidence
in the estimated values.
MLE methods provides
two major approaches
to constructing confidence
intervals or confidence
regions.
The first is the
asymptotic method, AM,
which assumes that the
likelihood function can
be approximated by a parabola
around the estimated parameter.
An assumption that is valid
for a very large sample.
The second is the
likelihood ratio, LR method.
The LR is the ratio of
the likelihood for a given
set of parameter values to the
likelihood for the MLE values.
The LR method involves searching
the actual likelihood surface
to find values of the
likelihood function
that yield a particular
value for the LR.
That value is derived for
the probability distribution
of the LR and the
confidence level
desired, such as 95% chance that
the true parameter value lies
within the confidence interval.
This tutorial will use the
Univariate Likelihood Ratio
for determining the MLE
competence interval in Vensim.
The estimated parameter
and competence interval
mean that for a specific
percentage of probability--
usually 95 or 99% that
the real parameter falls
within the confidence interval
with the designated percent
possibility.
This is consistent with
general applications
of statistics and probability.
The LR our method of
confidence interval
estimation compared to the
likelihood for the estimated
parameter, theta hat, with
that of an alternative set,
theta star.
The likelihood ratio is
determined in equation one
as R equals L theta hat
divided by L theta star.
Asymptotically, the
likelihood ratio
falls at chi square
distribution, equation two.
This is valuable, because the
univariate method requires
no new optimizations once
the MLE has been found.
The critical parameter
value for all parameters
is then simply using
equation three.
A disadvantage of univariate
confidence interval estimates,
however, is that the parameter
space is not fully explored.
Hence, the effect of interaction
between the parameters on LL
is ignored,
The tutorial now switches
to a real simulation
using Vensim 6.1.
It will show how the
theory just described
can be applied to estimating
parameters of decision-making
in the Beer Distribution Game.
SPEAKER 2: Hello.
This tutorial is now going
to explore analytics,
by estimating the parameters
for a well-analyzed model
of decision-making used in
the Beer Distribution Game.
The model is described in the
paper, "Modeling Managerial
Behavior-- Misperception
of Feedback in a Dynamic
Decision-Making Experiment" by
Professor Sterman from 1989.
Participants in the beer
game choose how much beer
to order each period in
a simulated supply chain.
The challenge is to estimate
the parameters of a proposed
decision rule for
participant orders.
The screen shows
the simple model
of beer game decision-making.
The ordering decision rule
proposed by Professor Sterman
is the following.
The orders placed every week
are given by the maximum of zero
and the sum of expected
customer orders-- the orders
that participants
expect to receive
next period from their
immediate customer and inventory
discrepancy.
The inventory discrepancy
is the difference
between total desired
inventory and some
of actual on-hand
inventory and supply
line of on-order inventory.
There are four
parameters that are
used in the model-- [INAUDIBLE],
the weight on incoming orders
in demand forecasting,
S prime, the desired
on-hand and on-order
inventory, the fraction
of the gap between desired and
actual on-hand and on-order
inventory ordered each
week, and the fraction
of the supply line the
subject accounts for.
As modelers, we don't
know what the parameters
of the actual game are.
But we have the data for actual
orders placed by participants.
And this data is read
from the Excel spreadsheet
into the variable,
actual orders.
Let's start from
some guesstimates
and assign the following values.
[INAUDIBLE], fraction
of discrepancy
between desired and
actual inventory,
and supply line fraction
are all equal to 0.5.
S prime, the total desired
inventory, is 20 cases of beer.
With these parameters, the
model runs and generates
some alias of the
order placed, which
can be seem on this graph.
Let's compare them
against the actual orders
observed in the beer game.
We can see that although
the trend is generally
correct at the high level, the
shape is totally different.
This necessitates the question,
how can we effectively measure
the fit of the data?
The typical way is to calculate
the sum of squared errors,
which are differences between
simulated and actual data
points.
Square, to make
sure negative values
don't reduce the total sum.
The basic statistics
of any variable
can be found by
using statistics to
from either object
output or bench tool.
For this tutorial, I
have already defined it.
And in this case, we can see
[INAUDIBLE] of sum of squares
of residuals is 1700,
with a mean of about 35.
This is pretty far
from a good fit,
and we can confirm
it officially.
Now let's see how to
run the optimization
to find the parameters that
will bring the values of orders
placed as close to the
actual orders as possible.
The optimization
control panel is
invoked by using optimized
tool on the toolbar.
When you first open, you have
to specify the file name here.
Also, it is necessary to specify
what type of optimization
you're going to do.
There are two types
that can be used.
They differ in the way they
interpret and calculate
the payoff value.
A payoff is a single number
that summarize the simulation.
In the case of
the simulation, it
will be a measure
of fit, which can
be a sum of squared
errors between the actual
and the simulated
values, or it can
be a true electrical function.
If you are only interested
in finding the best
fit without worrying about
confidence intervals,
you can use the
calibration mode.
For calibration, it is
not necessary to define
the payoff functional mode.
Instead, choose the model
variable and the data variable
with which the model
variable will be compared.
In Vensim, then
at each time step,
the difference between the
data and the model variable
is multiplied by the
weight specified.
And this product
is then squared.
This number, which
is always positive,
is then subtracted
from the payoff,
so that the payoff
is always negative.
Maximizing the
payoff means getting
it to be as close
to zero as possible.
However, this is not a true
log-likelihood function,
so the results cannot be used to
find the confidence intervals,
which we need.
Therefore, we're going
to use the policy mode.
For policy mode,
the payoff function
must be specified explicitly.
At each time step, the
value of the variable
or presenting a payoff function
is multiplied by the weight.
Then it is multiplied by time
step and added to the payoff.
The optimizer is designed
to maximize the payoff.
So variables, for
which more is better,
should be given
positive weights,
and those, for which
less is better,
should be given
negative weights.
Here, [INAUDIBLE] are specified
in the sum of squared errors.
Residuals are calculated as
the difference between orders
placed and actual orders
at each time step.
This squared value
is then accumulated
in the stock sum
of residual square.
The tricky part is the variable,
total sum of residual square.
Please note that because
Vensim, in the policy mode,
multiplies the values
of the payoff function
by the time step,
the payoff value
is the weighted combination
of the different payoff
elements integrated
over the simulation.
This is not what
we're looking for.
We are interested in the final
value of a variable instead
of the integrated value, because
the final value is exactly
the total sum of squared
errors the way we defined it.
Here's an example to
illustrate the concept.
In this line is a
stock variable level.
It can be seen that, if we
just use the stock of sum
of residual squared in
the payoff function,
we get the value, which is equal
to the area under the curve,
instead of the final
value that we need.
[INAUDIBLE] look at
only the final value.
In a model, it is necessary
to introduce new variable
for the payoff function and
use the following equation that
makes its value to be
zero at each time step,
except for the final step.
Add the current value of the
residual squared to the stock
level to account for the value
of the current time step.
This effectually ignores
all the intermediate values
and looks only at
the final value.
So far, this is
nothing different
from what Vensim was doing
in the calibration mode.
We simply replicated what it
would be doing automatically.
In order to get the true
likelihood function-- assuming
normal distribution
of errors-- we
need to divide the
sum of squared errors
by two variances.
This is what you can see in the
true low likelihood function
variable.
So far, in this
demonstration, we
don't know what the
standard deviation of errors
is going to be, because we
haven't optimized anything yet,
so we're going to leave
this variable as 1.
We are going to change
it to the actual value
of the standard deviation of
errors later by the confidence
interval.
Now let's change the
run name and go back
to Optimization Setup.
And let's use our log-likelihood
function as the payoff element.
Because this is
policy mode, we don't
need to specify anything
in Compare To field.
For the weight, because
this is policy mode,
it is necessary to
assign a negative value.
This tells Vensim
that we're looking
to minimize the payoff function.
If there are multiple
payoff functions,
the weight value would
have been important.
For one function,
it doesn't matter.
But we don't want
to change the values
of the log-likelihood function
to calculate true confidence
internal values.
Therefore, the log-likelihood
function will not be scaled,
and the weight is
going to be minus 1.
Next screen, the
Optimization Control Panel,
we have to specify
the file name again.
Then, make sure to
use multiple starts.
This means the
analysis is less likely
going to be stuck
at a local optimum
if the surface is not complete.
If multiple starts is
random, starting points
for any optimizations are
picked randomly and uniformly
over the range of
each parameter.
Next field, optimizer, tells
Vensim to use probable method
to find local minimum
function at each start.
Technically, you could
ignore this parameter
and just rely on
random starts to find
the values of a payoff function.
However, using multiple
starts together
with optimization
of each time step
produces better and
faster convergence.
The other values are left
at the default levels.
You can read more about these
parameter in Vensim help,
but generally, they
control the optimization
and are important for
complicated models
where simulation
time is significant.
Let's add now the parameters
that Vensim will vary in order
to minimize the payoff function.
Next, make sure Payoff Report
is selected and hit Finish.
For random or other random
values of multiple start,
the optimizer will
never stop unless you
click on the Stop
button to interrupt it.
If you don't choose
multiple starts,
the next few steps
are not necessary
as Vensim would be able
to complete optimization
and sensitivity analysis,
which is performed
in the final step
of optimization.
However, as I mentioned,
the optimization
can be stuck at a
local optimum, thus
producing some optimal results.
So it is recommended that you
use multiple starts unless you
know the shape of
the payoff function
and are sure that local optimum
is equal to the global optimum.
So having chosen
random multiple starts,
the question is, when to
stop the optimization.
This requires some
experiments and depends
on the shape of your
payoff function.
In this case, the
values of the payoff
have been changing quite
fast in the beginning
and are now at the same
level for quite some time.
So it's a good time to attempt
to interrupt the optimization
and see if you like the results.
As you can see, the shape
of the orders placed
is much closer to the
actual order values.
The statistics shows
a much better fit,
with the total sum of squared
error significantly lower
at the level of just 279,
with a mean of 5.813.
The values of the rest of
the optimized parameter
can be looked up in the
file with the same name
as the run name and
the extension out.
We can open this file from
Vensim using the Edit File
command from File menu.
So far, we only know the
optimal values, but not
the confidence intervals.
We need now to tell Vensim to
use the optimal values found
and calculate the confidence
intervals around them.
We are going to do it by using
the output of the optimization
and changing
optimization parameters.
To do this, first, we have to
modify the optimization control
parameters and turn
of multiple starts,
and optimize them, and save
it as the optimization control
type file, BOC.
Also, we need to change the
value of standard deviation
to the actual value
to make sure we're
looking at the true values of
the log-likelihood function.
This value can be found in the
statistics [INAUDIBLE] again.
We use it to change the
variable in the model.
Open the Optimization
Control Panel again,
and leave the payoff
function as it is.
But on the Optimization
Control Screen,
open the file that
was just created
and check that multiple starts
and optimizer are turned off.
In addition, specify [INAUDIBLE]
by choosing payoff value
and entering the value by
which Vensim will change
the optimal likelihood function
in order to find the constants
controls.
Because for likelihood
ratio method,
the likelihood ratio
is approximated
by the chi-square
distribution, it
is necessary to find the value
of chi-square distribution
[INAUDIBLE] for 95th percentile
for one degree of freedom,
because we are doing
the univariate analysis.
A disadvantage of univariate
confidence interval estimation
is that the parameter space
is not fully explored.
Hence, the effect of
interaction between parameters
and log-likelihood
function is ignored.
The value of chi-squared,
in this case,
is approximately
3.84146, which we're
going to use in the
sensitivity field.
Now, the [INAUDIBLE] button.
And as you see,
this time, we don't
have to wait as Vensim
doesn't do any optimization.
The results,
allocated in the file
that has the name of
the run-- and the word
sensitive with
the extension tab.
Let's open this file and
see our estimated parameters
and the confidence intervals.
Since we are using too much
more likelihood function,
the confidence bounds are
not necessarily symmetric.
This is a very simple tutorial.
I hope you are now more familiar
with [INAUDIBLE] for estimating
parameters and confidence
intervals for your models.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 3: A summary of the
seven key steps involved
in determining the MLE in Vensim
is contained on the slide.
It can be printed and
serve as a useful reference
and check for those
wishing to use the method.
MLE has its advantages
and disadvantages
in estimating parameters and
their confidence intervals
when performing
dynamic modeling.
In conclusion,
when the condition
of errors being independent
and identically distributed
are met, then MLE is a simple
and straightforward method
for estimating
parameters in determining
their statistical fit in system
dynamics models developed
in Vensim.